belarus is strong man
looking weak an address to his
traditionally loyal base of state
factory workers
met with heckles not cheers
step down they shout a president should
not make decisions as a result of
pressure
then a compromise he offers new
elections
after a referendum on the constitution
but as he flies off the protest swells
a day of strikes in anger at his
re-election nine days ago
and the police violence that followed
we want to support this movement people
go out into the street because the
authorities do not hear us
and a strike at the moment is the only
bloodless method
across the border in lithuania there's
worry the president may seek russia's
help
or the kremlin could intervene anyway we
are concerned because it's publicly
discussed
so i personally doubt it will happen but
you cannot exclude you know you cannot
say that it was never
the case lithuania is one of the
strongest european voices condemning the
regime
this country is also watching the
actions of russia closely
but the crisis in belarus is different
to the 2014
uprising in next door ukraine the
opposition
isn't pro-eu or pro-russia they're just
anti-alexander lukashenko leading the
charge is svetlana tikanaskaya
appearing in another video from hiding
i'm prepared to take responsibility and
act as the nation's leader during this
period
so the country settles down and gets
back to normality
her words will resonate back home but is
harmonious protest enough
to end 26 years of one-man rule
debra haynes sky news vilnius